let's go live to the u.s southern border
where national correspondent bill
malugen spoke to a group of migrants who
arrived there yesterday one person told
fox news
this about his journey listen
right now is the moment it's the moment
that we have the opportunity to come
here
and why do you feel right now is the
moment as opposed to maybe a year ago
anxious nervous it's like a a huge
amount of
feelings that i'm feeling right now
fox news is on the ground inside the
border city of del rio texas today our
crew has been tracking migrants
streaming across the rio grande
river bill set the scene for us what
else are you hearing and seeing
there this hour
yeah good afternoon so today was the
third day in a row that we've seen
a very large group of migrants cross the
rio grande directly behind us and just
present themselves to law enforcement
here
on the u.s side of the border here in
del rio this sector has become quickly
one of the most active sectors all along
the u.s mexico border and we'll show you
some of the video some of what we've
been witnessing these last three days
this video you're looking at now
we just shot a few hours ago this
morning this was the biggest group of
migrants we've seen
so far this was a group of 52
venezuelans who crossed the rio grande
when the water was running lower and
it's much safer and you can see some of
them had young children with them
some of them had infants some of them
were struggling in the current a little
bit once they got closer to this side
but
i had a chance to talk to some of these
folks one family telling me they
they crossed into colombia then they
paid somebody to take a flight into
mexico then they took a bus
kind of closer to the border crossing
where we're at right now many of these
venezuelans
telling us that they they fear the local
government in venezuela and they want a
better life so they came here
to the united states take a listen to
what one man told us as to why he came
here
with his wife and his two young children
i want i want security that's what i
want i want the security for my family i
want the security for us
and i i want to have a life
and you can hear that man getting
emotional there what we've seen every
day is video you're looking at now which
is that
local sheriff's deputies are having to
sort through these migrants when they
first present themselves here that's
because
border patrol isn't here right now
they're not waiting for these migrants
they have to get called in
and because they're so overwhelmed and
overextended it can sometimes take an
hour or two for border patrol to arrive
so
these local sheriff's deputies with val
verde county they got to do the sorting
then they hand them off to border patrol
and if you pull up that video
that's going to be what you're looking
at is a border patrol bus
when border patrol does arrive these
deputies hand them off and they bring a
big bus
and that's when they end up getting
processed but the local sheriff here
he's frustrated because while his
deputies are helping border patrol do
this and apprehending these migrants
they don't have time to respond
to local calls for service here in the
county if there's a shooting or a
stabbing
they're here doing this so the sheriff
is frustrated and he needs
he wants dc to send some help or figure
something out take a listen to what he
had to say
it's tying up our resources it's
frustrating because there's no
no answers that are being given there's
not a
there's not i don't believe that there's
a plan in place right now you know we
need more manpower we need people in dc
to make a decision do it do their job
and that's just here in del rio sector
if you pull up this video this is video
that the fox drone crew shot south of us
down in the rio grande valley this is in
la jolla texas this morning where
border agents on horseback had to track
down a group of about a dozen migrants
from the triangle countries
el salvador guatemala honduras take them
into custody
back out here live guys this is
happening all along
the u.s mexico border in almost every
sector here in del rio it's really
picking up the local sheriff saying
never in his life has he seen the
immigration situation get
this bad we'll send it back to you bill
thanks for
to you and the crew for bringing us all
the great video this morning we
appreciate